en polynésie française en a cinq espèces
de tortues marines présentes
il a même reconnu principalement donc
l'attention à briquet la tortue père ont
émis 2 et oncle demain polynésien au
bouquet à pour la tortue appliquée et et
on ou portugais il faut savoir pour en
parler après que sont des espèces qui
sont tellement impliqué dans la culture
polynésienne en boule d'azur général
pour pas qu'on oublie les françaises
elles ont énormément de gens différents
sont des archipels ont même des apports
en calories vides pour la même manière
chaque parties anatomiques à un nom
chaque développement apd chaque stade au
niveau du développement
ce sont des espèces il s'est facilement
qualifiée non seulement par
l'archéologie très particulière mais
aussi par rapport à la connaissance
traditionnelle peuples du pacifique
alors présents ainsi que lui qui est
particulier ce sont là les teams et
qu'elles ont développé une stratégie de
promotion qui finalement va favoriser un
très grand bravo deux qui vont être à
court du pour au final très peu de sur
l'hygiène pas des petites et un taux
très réduits de ces jeunes qui avaient
d'atteindre l'âge adulte
après une bonne à couper noir une panne
y avoir une série de la fécondation des
yeux et apporte alors je vous lis
quelques photos jusqu'au entre 30 et 40
ans tu partages tuner maman des jumelles
qui ont ensuite inégalée mais c'est la
burqa c'est très difficile c'est qu'il
ya plein de gens qui nous disent
mécontents du palais quand les nazis
est ce que c'est vrai qu'elles peuvent
faire pour les protéger alors on a vous
résidez étudier dans le passé en plus
une question à laquelle préparer entre
parce que c'est l'effet mêleront sur les
pages qu'on peut avoir d'estimation des
femelles qui fait vendre
moi jamais compter tous les individus
mâles et femelles qui sont présents dans
l'eau de pluie neige qu'ils ont mangé un
peu classique par pascal intéressant
c'est que la même femelle va s'appeler
la femelle à s'accoupler avec plusieurs
mâles différentes qui va occasionner un
brassage génétique important par rapport
à la pérennité des espèces et tient la
corde au cou les femelles vont venir
prendre à intervalles assez régulier de
douze à quinze jours plusieurs fois
la même saison une série une 5 à 2 elle
m'a enterré dans le sol et qui vont se
développer ensuite tout seul alors
accrue de quelque chose de très rare
dans le cadre d'un changement
actuellement la couverture des plages
qui est que le déterminisme du sexe des
petites ne se fait pas au moment de la
fécondation
mais pendant la phase d'accumulation de
réserves aussi il y admirer lance pour
la planète une augmentation de ces
températures moyennes
cela pourrait amener à ne produire que
des flots m je suis très important
lacombe se passe principalement la nuit
là on a tous les cas possibles 6 en
polynésie française
il y a juste que ça monte aussi
qu'elettra c'est à ce moment là les gens
qui me disent ah non mais jamie cullum
s'en passer dessus on dirait un tracteur
c'est pas compliqué contre le sang va
être 50 kg donfut qui monte sur une
plage en a trois c'est difficile de les
compter
désolé il va bien national à des menaces
du développement embryonnaire qui colle
bien sûr de paris bnf génétique ils
auraient tous les prédateurs ou de
crabes ici surnombre sur nos plages
bien sûr des fourmis je parle pas des
chiens des chats notre être bruyant
éventuellement est viable et c'est
pourquoi aussi illustre aussi la montée
des eaux si possible en explosion longue
houle assez importante que le nid des
parcs positionné assez ou sur la plage
base de liens tribaux des et a trouvé
plus d'une heure à deux heures pour le
mondial et les on aurait pu se
développer donc pour ces petites à
naître quand j'en mets n'avons pas
encore se développer
donc ça c'est très important d'avoir
cette idée d'augmenter les eaux qui peut
finalement perturbé tout ce succès de la
production après une période
d'incubation qui va 50 à 60 dijon en
moyenne acheter toutes les espèces
aviaires en particulier et mes photos
sont pratiquement des tentures sportif
il voyant des mains très attention les
petits au moment de l'éclosion coillard
également après quand ça doit sentir la
musique et respiration néonatale
or elles sont des fragments familles et
les ondulations zakho atteindre
elles vont bien sûr être menacée par les
animaux ce qui revient à une
perturbation liée à la lumière avoir
quelques titres dès qu'elles sortent des
caténaires du sable le nit à peu près 50
cm de profondeur voire plus elles sont
déterminées par deux choses premièrement
la nuit perd deux points de plus
lumineux maison à l'horizon et
deuxièmement descendant la pente si elle
sources lumineuses pâques et noël va pas
tiré et raté logue pas mourir on se
dessécher et sans augmenter pour aller
les rejoindre directement le lagon
quelque chose très intéressante que l'on
étudié les tâches sur le terrain ça va
être les petits qui sont en cuir une
centaine de juifs
bien sûr c'est un peu la première
histoire bête en mai progressant
pourquoi s'entraider donc on trouve
parfois mis des petits qui sont
tellement atypique elle arrive pas se
sentir seul
alors l'essentiel est qu'elles sont
viables et puis on va trouver une
manière prépare à tester ristic qui sont
pratiquement refoulés parce que les
volets 10 121 aux pétoncles et aux fins
d'une idée contrôle social a battu mary
n'a pas choisi la pelle plein de sa
gloire est l'unique a passé la pause et
à construire un besoin d'un petit peu
accidenté irlande c'est ce qu'on
retrouve mes pensées à sa signature est
il en train de lui consentent pour ça se
bat pour imprimantes canadien on pouvait
y mettre en place des plans de
conservation sur parent survivant d'une
elle a un qui va réussir à se développer
pour donner une adulte capable de se
reproduire
elles peuvent se reproduire qu'à partir
de 15h au canada corp donc c'est très
lent et pour ajouter un peu plus à
l'occasion pour ça on dit que sur une
centaine de rendu et la une car ils ont
évidemment
donc ça nous donne une idée des mesures
de conservation que l'or pourrait mettre
en place en 2010 arrive bien sûr mais
qui montre quand même que toute action
que l'on de mettre en place pour aider
ses juvéniles intensément web apps est
important que les populations de
cauchemar dans un seul premier point il
nous faisait manger par ailleurs appris
par rapport à des études on a fait sur
le nil 1 188 paris c'est que celles qui
viennent pour des symboles 10 en 16
on pense qu'elles sont nées ici qui est
donc les six peut pondre une fidélité
aussi par an ce qui fait que si on
découvre envolée n'hésita pourquoi c'est
cela qui vont protéger parce qu'on sait
que les adultes
en termes de stratégie de protection des
choses qui sont très claires et limpides
à mettre en place une fois que l'émotion
de vincent connu notamment les inventer
ensuite la menace les menaces qui pèsent
sur les tortues à lui alors bien sûr
dans le monde et j'ai rencontré quelques
exemples similaires puisque évolution
c'est innovant connivence est aussi on
n'est pas les zones les plus impactés
sur la planète une publication qui est
sorti rapidement les zones vraiment avec
le poteau de mentalité liés à la gestion
de plastique à propulsion pseudo la
gestion de batterie pâle dans superman
sa part immense et ce qui était vraiment
un contenu jay style d'une pointure non
pas que la gestion il ya des peuples
étranglement par isabelle et philippe
ainsi campé dans les filets conflit mais
j'y pense a derrière dans le web mais
aussi des captures volontaires en cause
par le braconnage principalement ici par
le fusil de chasse coach pour les
absents april acceptée par les accents
ici un film ils ont tous les villageois
qui fuient souvent des amputations et
puis habré est quelque chose de très
important c'est tout ce qu'ils veulent
et en longeant les plages ont finalement
une femelle elle y est qu'elle
s'applique à centre est à prendre et à
plus de place pour prendre donc ça ce
sont des exemples prix qu'on fait ici où
finalement on s'en voudrait pas contre
au début mais toutes ces manifestations
tous ces changements qu'il avait créée
par l'homme pourquoi la voiture et
patapon
s'il faut pas une page de compte alors
être capable d'aller un peu plus loin
elle va mettre à ses yeux est évoqué en
france
des mots puisque yoann ré mi je peux
juste quelques exemples que nous avons
mis en place en tunisie française avec
une association qui s'appelle des mano
khaimah pour l'un d'un ce qui veut dire
l'effet de serre quand on a créé en 2004
et pour laquelle on a donné prendre en
tête d'action qui sont l'éducation la
recherche et la conservation des milieux
marins politique française donc étendues
marines ont une
les espèces que nous étudions essayons
de mai pour prendre une jambe en
situation sur d'autres espèces marines
emblématiques que sont gênés par alain
par exemple vivante avant les les
iguanes sont les premiers à 100 nous
avons mise en cache et 2004 à la demande
d'audience sont l'environnement ça a été
pire
relation principal bien sûr mais que de
recueillir des tortues marines ils sont
valables blessés qui ont besoin de
l'aide soit pour pouvoir être sauvée à
gagner le large dans cette clinique a
été créée grâce à l'aide cieux perry qui
co fondateur de l'association pénalités
moins d'un an le cadre de l'ô canada
continental arborer un policier la
gravitation qui ne ferait qu'engendrer
la blonde naturelle bien pour en
dissuader limite pour une correspondance
dans cet espace qui met ses plus
importants pourquoi parce que les quand
tu m'as vu 90 va les sauver
arqués la phase de traitement initial
l'antibiothérapie etc
elles ont une phase de réhabilitation il
doit permet assez vite quand on les
relâche
d'abord une récupération rapide j'ai eu
l'occasion de visiter de nombreux
centres de soins actuels partout dans le
monde et la plupart du temps ce sont
dans les bassins embêtant avec une
lumière artificielle avec des types en
tout ce qui fait que même si elles sont
à la fois de nouveaux médicaments après
pas mal à reprendre leur vie naturelles
d'environnement classique
donc ça c'est un point très très
important on avait sur une autorisation
ministérielle sera leur appui à cette
actu
on mesure combien 400 en disant on n'a
aucune idée au départ finalement plus on
communique sur ses actions plus on se
rend compte qu'on voit des tortues et
sur ces 400 on a pu en réagissant 87
encore renaud madier après avoir été
habité là sur baguette ont acheté
identifier donc on fait les actions de
soins hospitaliers classique avec les
diagnostics des traitements et des
structures des radios nous avons
également reçu une tortue caouanne ici
qui est nouveau et même si on a pu poser
des balises yann danis sur son bureau et
elle nous a fait une très longue
migration massifie par entendre
impressionnant en cours à 14 8 km en un
an et demi et également quelques tôles
ivato croisic occasion neige qui sont
les grands gagnants
je partage avec les courants de
braconnage c'est quelque chose casser en
même temps que le site français ça quand
tu par exemple découvert par une fois
défendu et a pas on a plus de monde et
conseille donc je retire la flèche
qu'elles puissent être transférés dans
le transfert par avion pour son désir
hilton a fini par la soigner et accord à
l'arraché envoyer ses primes en général
mais plusieurs points havre pour les
relâcher
mais ma bible mon exemple adjoindre la
suite quand tu fais chier alors tu fais
chier ça représente
voilà 60 % de temps du consol à binic
pour mater parole et vous êtes actuel p
36 cm 4 kg a été pêché dans le coup a
déclaré françois hollande pour l'heure
c'est tortue il n'ya rien arranger
dessus et en plus c'est une tortue
imbriquée toxiques puisque elle
s'alimente desgranges qui en occident
générer leurs chèvres la consommation
mais il n'ya pas que ça les françaises
aussi beaucoup d'autres menaces sur les
peintures marines cet exemple dans tout
ce qui est à la lt atabak de se nourrir
donc vers les temples parce qu'elle ne
trouvait pas la nourriture et décote par
rapport à son point de croissance
mais finalement avec des semoirs
brouille et surtout une alimentation
encours clients la russie à la chine
donc c'est ainsi de voir que il ya
beaucoup de facteurs environnementaux
qui les impacts alors on essaie de faire
passer coin de recherche va servir les
besoins de recherche sur les sites de
ponte
on essuie le monde a repris le nom de
vente et tortueux quantités différentes
l'archipel de la société
pour avoir une idée des sites
prioritaires de pente et finalement la
russie justement d'un certain lien avec
avec des tirs à son sulky la famille
bongo et le teil prendre un essai avec
la base d'une étude détaillée sur la
tomate et thiaroye
alors on y va depuis 2004 on a vraiment
bien suivi régulière passent depuis 2007
alors mission il ya les dépeindre avec
des bateaux de pêcheurs l'empêchera
maintenant vingt sept équipes
laboratoire d'accueil qui nous permet
d'avoir une présence plus facile sur mes
disques on aurait quand même c'est que
vous en savez c'est que les tortues
marines et même pas compte de tous les
ans ce ne sont pas les mêmes depuis
vingt trois ans
2 à 4 ans et on sait que quand on sent
pas ici les adultes en général vertu est
reparti à la hausse vers physique on
s'alimente et dans ses passes condamné
parce qu'on dit ici que d'un seul coup
il faut sauver a alors attention il y en
a plus c'est président banda les étudier
sur du long terme
allez perdre un suivi d'une année savoir
seulement rien on arrive aussi grâce à
ça à mettre en place des produits des
données les inrocks en avant le niveau
depuis que ces noirs d'une année sur
l'autre si les modifications
il y aussi permettre très importante du
nombre de la profondeur unis lourd de
petit corps elle s'est sentie à milan
pour donner des informations importantes
découvertes dans un cadre d'une
protection qui voudraient mettre en
place en se balançant des élections des
chiffres réels une amitié avec mon suivi
très détaillé on va jusqu'à pour chacun
des mots tout établir une cartographie
en fonction des années avec une tortue
qui vont t'aimer qui n'a pas vendu dans
tu qualité qui a besoin du lait chez
l'avant du corps y avaient découvert
petit son lit comme un hymne rsa à
donner des chiffres
matic bien sûr nous conviennent petit
son nez sur la toile dans une même année
vivre des choses très intéressantes au
niveau scientifique on essaie partager
avec nos collègues scientifiques
vous avez raison les choses comme ça de
tortue jumelles après je même
s'acquitter de ces frais
n'écoutant tu as de tête investissez
quand même largement développé quelque
chose contre pratiquement nulle part
ailleurs
nous quand tu as munoz ou d'en tuer ici
vous voyez qu'il ya l'âge même photo une
tortue qui est mort dans l'explosion
mais voyez un classique une statue 6 ou
tortue qui a été mal an le trial envers
l'avs a vu survie nomination et
finitions valaisan succès n'ont pas
assisté à l'émergence ya certes eu des
mots l'abandon que ce sont des choses
comme un argument aussi bien sûr nous
avons eu la chance de faire quelques
suivi satellitaire d'en savoir assez
tortueux josemi avec amp ici quand tu
regardes et tu y vas et gaziers en bref
quality qu'est ce qu'elle fait là bas on
se posait s'alimente elle se repose il
vient sans doute de là
nous avons aussi un développé une
technique on sait que les compteurs même
c'est une question importante notamment
dans l'aventuré briquet qui n'étaient
pas tendres sur la plage et donc on
avait levé cette technique adapté
période technique des prix par le crioc
sur l'obligation faite à centrer vers
6hoo du matin sont embarqués à leur
bateau et il compte le plus tendu qu'il
voit sur les coraux récifaux de
certaines villes et 5000 m en face une
4e graphie on fait plusieurs fois dans
l'année et en exploitant les hommes ou
ces populaires sont majoritairement
présente avec des en abondance dans tout
ça c'est pareil c'est quoi la clé de la
journée pour pouvoir mieux les protéger
et attaquer plupart de conservation du
pays et puis pour finir notre
association s'est vraiment donné comme
mission principale d'éducation du grand
public principalement des jeunes et des
scolaires pour des mots énormément de
courage qui éducatif sous les trois
thématiques donc le tortues marines à
guitare ainsi qu'oracle prenant en
disant accueilli plus de soixante huit
mille enfants dans pour le pédagogique
sens dans notre structure nous avons la
chance d'avoir un entraîneur qui a été
construit sans nous allons les écoles
mouvement et supports pédagogiques
adaptés en français en utilisant de la
placière maison en anglais et on les
distribue dans tous les critiques
pacifique sud pour laisser les changer
et on partage un qui veut tout ce que
l'on fait on fait également des amis
grand public alors je vous en tout cas
très satisfaisant parce que ça va
prendre un peu les thématiques de ce
soit la fin d'un camion pour les uns du
maryland cherche un barrage peut être
rangée l'addition elle sait qu'elles
sont peu d'absorber cette modification
des courants d au moins trois permis
pour la pointe ou pour trouver la zone
d'alimentation générer les deux
thématiques eu de farce et
l'augmentation des plages les
destructions des plages puisque j'ai dit
au début c'est que si la température
monte
elle va produire que des femelles les
mâles à l'espace comprend de suite plus
disparaître
malheureusement il est classé de mal
pour l'introduction est l'un des points
là c'est l'implication de la population
locale
parce que les rangs des questions sur ça
mais ils ont su marina sont présentes
les portugais sont construits dans
l'actuelle une réglementation que je
disais qu'il interdit dans la chance est
donnée comme mission mais c'est de
sensibiliser un plus grand nombre
bon nombre de personnes et notamment le
support d'un public alors c'est souvent
scolaire en trempant ses portes au
public
donc là je vous montre l'exemple parce
qu'on a fait un français et un tahitien
et on essaie d'impliquer les populations
locales quand on m'a demandé si plateau
l'éloigneront lessive retrouver des gens
qui sont intéressés par la thématique
qui va collaborer avec bombes et que
l'on forme surnom techniques de collecte
tournée ont pas puissent y être référent
dans la ville sur ces actions là
lorsqu'un longtemps aussi dérouté
qu'intéressant et guérison a commencé à
l'ancien développer ce système est comme
une des clefs du succès ça serait
vraiment ce réseau de référents dans
toutes les hypothèses histoire et
d'actifs pour que les gens qui sont sur
site notamment s'est cependant les infos
sur le secteur ce qui est très loin du
village qui vont les occupants puissent
avoir fait remonter les informations etc
ont pu s'y coller voilà donc finalement
ça peut être une source de questions
c'est vrai que l'on est actuellement en
phase 1 battante ici en polynésie
française par rapport à la culture
vous avez une place importante en
espèces emblématiques notamment d'un
garde de modification de verser aux
mondiaux il est là parce qu'on la voit
mission de l'isie française et à quoi ça
va étudier mais voilà merci